362 million people don't have internet
access in China That's roughly 30
million more people than the entire U.S
population but this rocket holds a
possible solution to help China close
the gap
inside it are low earth orbit satellites
capable of providing high-speed internet
access even in remote areas
in China this technology is still
experimental
but starlink a subdivision of the
American company SpaceX has already
launched
4768 of them making it the leader across
the globe although space is vast these
satellites operate in a specific area
that's quickly getting more crowded to
ensure its place China is building up
its capabilities just two decades ago
59.1 million people in China were online
just 4.6 percent of its population then
now it's over 1 billion people 74 of the
population so is the country known for
its rapid development capable of
rivaling starlink
of the roughly 8 000 functioning
satellites currently in orbit about 55
percent belong to starlink and the
position of its satellites is key for
decades satellite internet providers
relied on geostationary satellites these
satellites are far away about 22 000
miles above the Earth's surface
that distance lets them cover a large
area and reach remote parts of the globe
but it takes longer for data to travel
between the satellite and the user this
means the Broadband has high latency and
slower speeds often geostationary
satellites offer speeds at least 25
megabits per second which is enough to
stream in HD and can support about one
to three devices
but satellites in low earth orbit or Leo
are much closer no more than 1200 miles
from Earth's surface
this means that while a Leo satellite
can't cover as much area as a
geostationary satellite it can provide
more stable and faster internet speeds
though SpaceX got its start launching
Rockets it has built up a big business
selling Broadband powered by Leo
satellites
and a key to its success it owns every
step of the process
SpaceX manufactures the satellites and
launches them with its own Falcon 9
rockets and Falcon 9 boosters the part
that blasts the rocket off the ground
are reusable saving SpaceX money on
launch costs they have a very capable
launch division that is regularly
blasting satellites off or customers for
governments and for itself and it can
launch dozens of satellites into low
earth orbit per trip
in 2014 China opened its space sector up
to private investment five years later
startups in China received over 314
million dollars in funding the only
country that attracted more startup
funding was the US in the same year
SpaceX alone received 962 million
dollars
to be more self-sufficient China has
been investing in key Tech like Leo
satellites
in 2021 it established satnet a
state-owned company it hopes will
streamline the process to launch
satellites and form a Broadband Network
so far China says it will build at least
7 800 satellites
plus the China Aerospace Science and
Technology Corporation and the China
Aerospace Science and Industry
Corporation have each launched
experimental satellites into low earth
orbit
and startup Galaxy space launched
several operational satellites last year
to begin its 1 000 satellite
constellation but so far no Enterprise
in China has created a rocket to launch
these satellites that's as advanced as
the falcon 9.
however Beijing Kim Bing technology
appears to be getting closer while the
company doesn't have a reusable rocket
yet it sent a liquid fuel rocket into
orbit for the first time earlier this
year experts say this is a crucial step
to creating a reusable rocket ultimately
the company wants to develop rockets
that can deploy up to 60 satellites in a
single launch similar to Falcon 9's
capabilities it's not easy to like get
off of Earth and like deploy you know
hundreds or thousands or tens of
thousands of satellites into that part
of space you need a rocket that can you
know make those trips over and over and
over again satellites in low earth orbit
have a shelf life they have to be
replaced so you need to have a
capability to kind of continually launch
satellites altogether this makes the
barrier to entry quite High McKinsey
estimates the cost to launch an operable
constellation is between 5 to 10 billion
dollars with yearly operating costs
running another one to two billion
dollars so what's the benefit the market
plays that spacex's
always been after is is global SpaceX
said in April that starlink was
available in more than 50 countries and
within the next few years it expects to
operate in many more countries across
Africa and Asia SpaceX has been going
around the world to get permission from
National Regulators to sell Starling
connections but it's not a loan
cooperation in space is a key part of
China's belt and Road initiative a
global infrastructure project
last year China said it had formed 149
space cooperation agreements with 46
National Space agencies and already it's
provided countries across Africa Europe
and Asia with bado a global navigation
satellite system that Rivals U.S owned
GPS major Chinese companies built
infrastructure across the world too up
to 70 percent of 4G network
infrastructure across Africa was built
by Huawei there are you know
billions of people around the world that
don't have any Internet at all beyond
that there's like huge demand just
generally for high-speed internet
and that demand is part of what's
driving starlink China and companies
everywhere to build these Leo
constellations but satellite internet at
least right now faces like real cost
challenges relative to traditional on
the ground terrestrial infrastructure
for internet connections I don't think
that like low earth orbit satellites
will take over and provide like Global
high-speed internet capacity one of the
biggest concerns facing the sector's
expansion is overcrowding in low earth
orbit by 2030 U.S officials estimate
there will be 58 000 satellites about a
725 percent increase from the number in
the sky right now
in just the past two years the FCC
received applications for more than 64
000 satellites and experts at Nasa and
the FCC fear that more satellites could
mean more issues already there are over
26 000 pieces of debris at least the
size of a softball in low earth orbit
that could destroy a satellite on impact
if you assume that like tens of
thousands of additional satellites are
launched and deployed to low earth orbit
in the coming years there's going to be
a real need for coordination
communication finding ways for all these
operators to sort of
know where their devices are are located
how they're moving and what like the
Potential Threat is for a collision
low earth orbit it's sort of like a
Commons right now there's some treaties
that govern space and there are also
what extroverts and government officials
call Norms around good space Behavior
it's a little more open-ended and
dependent on actors there to sort of
work together and communicate
foreign